ja ich habe mal wieder kein mädchen für
dieses video
deswegen spiele ich finde das mädchen
ich hoffe das ist okay das klappt jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video sorry
das letzte woche nichts kam ich war mega
in stress hatte überhaupt kein
zeitgerecht leid aber heute geht
natürlich weiter ja ich habe letztens
dieses video dinge die mädchen beim
chatten falsch waren rausgehauen und das
kamen mega gut war ich an da haben wir
gedacht kommen machst du doch einfach
mal noch sowas ähnlich ist und zwar
jetzt heute wm-titel bestimmt schon
gelesen habt um dinge die mädchen beim
date falsch machen und ja ich weiß jetzt
kommen wieder 10.000 kommentare kannst
du dich auch im wagen was jungs falsch
machen das ist eigentlich auch fast das
gleiche aber ich kann halt nicht
beurteilen was ist falsch man ist doch
klar und der zweite und das ist
natürlich nur meine meinung jeder hat
eine andere meinung wir gar nicht labern
viel spaß wenn ihr bock auf noch sonne
voll gehabt da das ist auf jeden fall
nach oben daran weiß bescheid und haben
jetzt ist hier ein bisschen hell
geworden aber die turner aus oder wird
sagen gefangen wie immer natürlich mit
punkt eins hat und zwar was wirklich so
meiner meinung nach sind diese mädchen
die dir die ganze zeit erzählen was sie
alles schon gemacht haben wie geil sie
sind was sie alles so zu hause besitzen
die halt so rum prallen müsst ihr also
so dass hier ja also ich war also meine
ganze familie und ich hier fliegen hat
normalerweise die ganzen sechs wochen
immer nach amerika pendeln also ein
bisschen zwischen las vegas ll be und so
dies war es irgendwie ein bisschen blöd
weil ich wollte
althaus damit nach hause geflogen ich
bin halt eigentlich so mit mir kannst du
etwas anfangen weil ich bin schon
ziemlich so besser als die anderen
manchmal sagen wir einfach noch leben
gegeben für hier an weiteren shop mit
der besten freundin deren eltern sind
auszureichen einer aber ich glaube meine
sind sogar noch ein bisschen weicher ist
halt nicht so toll auf jeden fall würde
ich sagen für mich das gar nicht weiter
drüber aufregen jetzt gemeinsam mit
punkt 2 und zwar ist das eigentlich
meiner meinung nach somit das ab ernste
hat man also keine ahnung was es gibt ja
und damit meine ich wenn die hand die
ganze zeit nur davon erzählt für alko
und die jede woche trinkt wie oft die
schon so mega absolut hatte die opti
schon gekotzt hat kennt ihr das ist okay
aber geil ich feiere dich natürlich ne
also so macht es immer oh ja das ist
doch schon so ein bisschen sagen wenn es
um alkohol geht da bin ich immer ganz
oben mit dabei und das hat sie mir
glauben zum beispiel letztens nicht ich
war mal wieder so freunde ich hab's von
übertrieben die partie gegen so um halb
neun los glaube ich und ohne scheiß um 9
uhr weicher trotzdem volle das kannst du
mir glauben jetzt war so lustig und
hängen die jungs fällt wenn ich dann
abgeholt von meiner eltern ich weiß dass
er davon natürlich nichts mehr wie
eigentlich immer wenn ihr gegenüber euch
wieder hat es krachen lassen
ab dann noch mal so schön uns das auto
völlig kurz hatten meine freundin am
nächsten tag erzählen weil die mann
neben mir dabei mit mir feiern zu gehen
dass man auch wenn man spaß hat kann es
mir glauben
okay da hört mich voll an
naja ok vielleicht ein bisschen zu kraft
dargestellt aber solche fälle zwischen
lauf und was wirklich auch noch dass das
klingt einfach richtig auch du willst
dabei aggressiv wenn du halt so da sitzt
und die mühe gibst dein handy zu gucken
und dann halt bei der gegenüber sitzt in
person so das passiert und du denkst dir
so eine art hause bleiben können
wörth ich habe mir mal eben schnell die
sprache meiner besten freundin der
muslime antworten es ist schlimm wenn
das ist schlimmer als damals machst du
willst du auch nur sagen sagte
projektsprecher es gar keines net vill
manner geschichte warte mal kurz oder
nebel machen dazu einmal kurz einmal
kurz gucken ja date dann machen damals
sprachen und ist dies das blabla kommt
wir machen das snap photos okay war wohl
nicht warum nicht mehr wir machen weiter
mit dem letzten punkt und zwar dass das
verstehe ich nicht ich verstehe ich
nicht wieso macht man dann überhaupt
sowas also passt auf folge ist man
trifft sich halt mit irgendeiner und die
erzählen dann die ganze zeit irgendwas
davon ja jungs mit einem voll scheiße
also alle mit denen ich bisher so
zusammenhalten scheiße ich hoffe du bist
nicht so scheiße da denke ich mir so
wenn du alles scheiße findet wieso
machst du das seien hier gerade woanders
sind
soll ich dir eigentlich mal von meinem
letzten freund erzählt und also das war
das größte arschloch ohne mist und da
mein vater vor der reich auf das größte
auch schon mal wieder gemerkt dass
eigentlich alle jungs gleich sind es
gibt wirklich keinen den man ein
bisschen besser deren eiskalt was mit
meiner besten freundin angefangen das
habe ich dann auch noch von meiner das
verfahren nicht mal von ihm und ich
musste dem immer schreiben der mir
geschrieben warum man das war das ist so
weil wir alle jungs
pleite sind die größten arschlöcher
folge völlig persönlich wisst ihr was
ich damit meine so das ist irgendwie das
ergibt einfach keinen sinn es ergibt
keinen sinn
snapshot ins all war alles eingewendet
bitte noch nicht wegschalten ich habe
auch so einem kurzen tipp für euch und
zwar ein ganz guter kumpel von mir dann
schon etwas länger sein job hat mir auch
mal ein paar sachen zu geschenk ich zeig
dir euch einfach mal schnell und zwar
ist er zum beispiel dieses fresh ort wo
das neue team alex inhalt und zum
beispiel auch noch diese session rudi
oder wie man das nennt oder pullover
eine billige einfach auf jeden fall
ziemlich leichte sachen ich trage das
gerne und wir sind auf jeden fall für
für jede für mendig für weibliches alles
was dabei auch ziemlich preis werden
deswegen check das mal würde mich freuen
link ist interview beschreibung liegt
dafür können geld versprochen und ja
hier oben rechts geht's weiter mit
meinem das video das war tags einfach
mal ab dann werden wir das sehen es war
halt so
mal was anderes sein also irgendwie
ergibt das keinen sinn aber checks auf
jeden fall mal ab wir sehen uns nicht
mittwoch wieder auch cooles video kommt
auf jeden fall noch ein oder zwei ps
sowie aus jetzt hier beenden